we all know the pain you're trying to
learn a new trick or a new technique and
it just seems to be taking forever in a
day is there any way that you can speed
up that learning process and make it a
little bit less painful well I have some
ideas and I will share them with you in
this
video Drex here from Drex Factor Poise
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning in flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and in this video we're
going to talk about strategies for
speeding up your learning so you can get
from point A to point B just a little
bit faster but before we dive in I do
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyrro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca beckon thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission ah so it was a beautiful day and
I spent most of it inside writing
scripts and editing and I want to take
advantage of a little bit of it but we
are probably about 45 minutes away from
a rainstorm hitting so let's see if I
can get this in before that happens all
right so first up I'm going to share
stuff that I know is backed up by
science and then we're going to talk
about some of my own personal thoughts
on the matter but the answer to the
question is it possible to speed up your
learning yes I think that it is I also
do need to say though that sometimes
things are hard to learn and it just
takes a lot of patience to get there and
if you're not seeing immediate results
that doesn't mean that you're never
going to get to your goal sometimes it
just means that you need to make your
peace with the fact that that Journey
might be a little bit longer than you
would like but it will happen now all
that said there are some ways that you
can speed up your learning and make it
more likely that you're going to hold on
to the knowledge that you're acquiring
so let's talk about what some of those
approaches are so tip number one is to
eliminate distractions this may seem
like a small thing but the process of
learning a new skill or new information
is something that involves us having to
focus on that thing for a certain amount
of time and if you're constantly being
distracted by say I I don't know maybe
notifications on your phone or something
in your environment that is uh kind of
distracting you something noisy
something bright so on and so forth then
you're going to have a really hard time
focusing long enough to be able to
acquire that information or skill so do
what you can to eliminate those
distractions maybe you put on headphones
when you're practicing uh maybe you put
your phone on do not disturb mode or as
I like to do when I'm practicing uh I
actually set up my phone to record
myself as I'm practicing so therefore I
can't possibly check the notifications
and also it has the Practical use of me
being able to go back and review my
practice and see how I did that day and
speaking of practice that takes us to
tip number two because you are
practicing regularly right right you'd
be shocked at how big a difference it
makes to make your practice a regular
thing that you do say like a half an
hour every day uh as opposed to like
maybe you sit down to work on something
for a few minutes every week or every
other week when we're working regularly
we're building new neurological
connections when we don't work regularly
it makes it so much harder to set down
those connections I know it can be a
pain in the butt and I know that you
don't feel motivated to do it every day
but the more regular you can make a
practice ritual the more religiously you
can follow that the more you're going to
see progress and you're going to see it
quickly because you'll be working really
really diligently at building those
connections and it'll make a huge
difference trust me and yes I know it's
sucks to keep on working at practicing
something for days on end and feel like
you're not seeing any real progress and
yes that does suck but just because
you're not seeing immediate progress
does not mean that you're not making any
progress at all have some faith and do
as I do and record some of your practice
sessions so you can go back later and
see oh I was making progress the whole
time it was just so incremental that I
didn't catch it you'd be amazed how
often that happens all right so tip
number three and this is kind of a weird
Neuroscience thing but um there's a book
I read a while ago called the first I
think it's the first 20 hours um that is
all about trying to acquire new skills
quickly and one of the gems in that book
was discovering that once you get to be
an adult something that happens every
time you go to sleep is that your brain
is going to go through and it's going to
prune neurological Connections in your
brain um this happens a lot less when
you're younger and it increases as you
get older now the thing is is that
despite that pruning it is still
possible to add new connections and in
fact one of the things the experts uh
recommend now is that if you are trying
to acquire a new skill that you practice
it in the evening uh wrap up with it no
later than say like an hour before you
go to bed and it turns out all those
connections are going to be fresh enough
that they're more likely to survive that
pruning at night so this is kind of a
cool little brain hack that you can do
to speed up your learning just a little
bit now all of that said it is way more
important to have a regular practice
routine than it is to have a practice
routine in the evening so if that's not
possible do not stress it just make sure
that you're getting your practice in
regularly but if you can do both that is
get in that regular practice routine and
do it in the evening right before you go
to bed the results are going to be a lot
faster all right so now we are off the
beaten path of stuff that I know that
there is good scientific literature
backing up that yes these things do uh
increase the speed at which you learn
new things now we're getting into stuff
that I personally think helps you learn
faster and uh you can take this or leave
it but uh if I come up with data on this
at any point I'll leave a link down in
the description to let you all know that
I was right all right so the first of
these items is going to be something
that one once again is going to seem
like it is uh rather inconsequential but
I swear it does make a difference and
that is in addition to having a regular
practice routine making sure that you
have a regular warm-up ritual that goes
with it um this kind of fits somewhere
in the realm of like ritual or classical
conditioning and psychology wherein you
put uh two stimuli together and
Associate the two and it means that they
kind of augment each other I person
think that when you have a regular
warm-up ritual that you do before you
start your practice that then puts your
brain in a place where it is prepared to
do work and prepared to focus on
whatever you're working on when you do
practice and I think this does make a
difference I think it tends to mean that
you get more out of that time that you
spend practicing and also to that it is
quicker and easier to get your brain
into Focus mode for it and this can take
many many different forms person Al when
I warm up uh I tend to do the 24 form of
uh young style ta Chi um I also have a
little POI dance warm-up that I do and
not only does that loosen up my body and
get it ready to move around but also too
it gets me focused and it gets my body
and brain just thinking in a different
way than I normally do and I always find
that to be helpful and now my final tip
tip number five just have to do with how
you practice um whenever there's
something new that I'm trying to learn I
try to break it up into smaller pieces I
find that it is much more difficult to
as they say try and eat an elephant in
one bite than it is to try and see what
smaller pieces that I don't currently
have make it up so to give you an
example of this a few years ago I
decided to uh learn how to do
Gunslingers and I specifically wanted to
learn Gunslingers so that I could do
anti been Gunslinger flowers so over the
course of 3 months I broke down every
single step that I needed to get there I
started off by just learning basic uh
Gunslinger meteor weaves with each hand
both forwards as well as reverse two
beats and then learning how to do uh
waist straps going back and forth
between them and specific anti-spin
flowers with each tube and then over
time I realized that I was also going to
need to learn how to perform these
weaves with each hand next to each other
and in the process of that I discovered
that there were four different ways to
orient that so I spent a bunch of time
breaking down how to perform these uh
these Gunslinger weaves with two hands
phased in a variety of different ways
finally I would practice having my hands
go up and down and then come back
together and try and control how many
reps of the weave that I did every
single time the hands came together over
time and it did take time it worked I
got the trick it took me a while though
but if I hadn't broke it down into those
smaller pieces I never would have gotten
it I would have just been hitting my
head against a wall for months if not
years trying to figure out how to do
this very complex thing that I saw in a
video so when you're approaching trying
to do anything figure out what the
smaller steps that it's made out of
actually look like if you encounter a
place where you're struggling try and
figure out what is the skill or
technique that is occurring here that I
don't currently have and see if you can
find a way to practice that specific
technique and make it easier for you and
that way not only are you more likely to
fulfill your goals but also too you'll
have a lot more incremental progress
you'll have a lot more small things that
go along the road that you'll be able to
look to and say sweet I got that down
and that'll help your confidence in the
short term and of course now that I'm
wrapping this video up the rain has
finally arrived so it looks like I'm
going straight back in ah easy come easy
go anyhow thank you for joining me for
this nice little walk and talk I hope
that these tips were helpful if you got
anything out of this video please make
sure to like share comment and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel grow
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I want to give a shout out to
my flow patrons who are listed on screen
right now thank you so much all of you
all rock and if you would like to get
your name in the credits like these
awesome flow patrons or any of the other
rewards that I have available you can go
sign up at my patreon at
patreon.com factor pooy and help me
spread the love of Po spinning and flow
Arts around the whole wide world go
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like more tips on how to get
more out of your practice sessions I
will go ahead and leave a link to a
video that I did on that topic a while
back down in the description as well as
up on the screen thank you so much for
watching make sure to out and flow today
I hope it doesn't rain on you and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace